um the next step forward is really with
liberal arts and graduate education
which are 19th century creations largely
there's greater inclusion
there's breadth but also specialization
this is a year of the classic education
where every young man of a certain class
had to learn Greek and Latin but also
Snatcher 'el science and philosophy but
they were still very exclusive
institutions in terms of gender race
class right so this is Rosa Luxemburg
one of my great here wins how many of
you have ever heard of Rosa Luxemburg my
students have heard of her one of the
least one of whom is here Rosa Luxemburg
was a very important political economist
at the turn of the the early part of the
20th century the last part of the 19th
her death was by drowning she was
murdered by the germans at the end of
World War one because of her social
beliefs she was a Democrat social
democrat she was the socialist she was a
communist and fought with limb Lenin had
a different view of organizing she was a
very ambitious woman who wanted to go to
graduate school and she found in this
wonderful graphic novel called red Rosa
this is the image from that she found
that there was a graduate school that
accepted women the University of Zurich
and so she went to the University of
Zurich and graduated from there with a
PhD in 1887 just to give you a sense so
that it wasn't that long ago right how
hard it was for women to get an
education
another hero in of mine is Gertrude
Stein who went to Radcliffe studied with
William James so she learned psychology
and philosophy then went to Hopkins
Medical School because it was one of the
only place as a woman could go on and
get a degree she was bored there and
left to go to Paris to become the
Gertrude Stein we know using some of the
things she learned from William James in
the
of writing her poetry my own experience
in getting an education involved a place
called Western High School in Baltimore
it was the first public high school that
women could attend I was not in the
first class that was in 1844 Walt
Whitman gave the convocation speech but
it was it still exists and it's got this
very long history was created as a place
where woman women could go there was an
Eastern and a western because women
couldn't travel very far from where they
lived and it really prepared women to be
teachers not University teachers
teachers of young children and it grew
from that so it became one of the famous
places for college preparatory work a
public high school right others followed
suit I then chose to go to Bryn Mawr
College which had a similar history but
for universities founded in 1855 again I
was not in the first class though I am
getting close to feeling like I was and
it was a place that was the first
college for women that did two things
one it followed the Harvard model in
terms of standards so it was the highest
standard of any place that women could
go and the second thing it did was
provide the first graduate program at a
women's college so it's one of the first
and only places women could get a
college a grad both a college education
of a very high quality and a graduate
education so that's what formed me so
you can see why I care about these
issues of exclusion this is james
Meredith and Ole Miss just to remind you
about how recently our universities were
exclusive this is not that long ago this
is the 1960s now there were exceptions
Harvard was founded as an Indian College
Native American college there were the
historically black colleges that got
formed but nonetheless until very very
recently colleges and universities in
the United States as well as elsewhere
were extremely exclusive they've opened
up they really opened up in the
post-world War two ERA more than any
other time
[Music]